battle of zach's today
davies for the cubs gallon for the
d-backs
here is the note of the day yeah it is
zac day here at wrigley however that's
not all ladies and gentlemen
may i have your attention
the braves and the phillies play today
zach wheeler goes for the phillies the
padres
and the marlins play zach thompson goes
for the marlins and the rays and the
indians zach pleck on the mound it's a
five zack day in major league baseball
of course cubs for friday home games
where the city connect uniforms
goes to sinker
at 88 miles an hour change up the plus
pitch 33 percent of the time so relies
heavily on that change up occasional
curve ball occasional cutter five and
six with a four three five
era
three two
and that one
oh foul tip yeah no it's not about tip
bill welky saying out
well i don't think tory lavello is
getting any satisfaction here i'm not so
sure that they are going to overrule
this call i mean the base umpires they
can't
i'm sorry that's on me i think
popped up right side shallow right nico
horner drifting back he's under it and
he's got it one away
in the pitches swung on and missed
straight three
scooped in the air left field brian
coming on high socked look for chris
that's the third out right-hander zack
gallon his second start since coming off
the injured list for the third time this
year he's looking for his first win
since april 25th that game in atlanta he
certainly pitched well enough to win
last time out against these cubbies went
five and two-thirds gave up one run on
three hits
and a swing and a miss
and you talk about a hitter that was
messed up against gallon men at first
and second here in the bottom half of
the first inning in the cleanup man
javier baez duo
left center field that one on its way
out of here javi baez touch them all
three nothing cubs said all the time if
you spin it and he can reach it he's
going to put a pretty good swing on it
usually and this ball is at the bottom
of his own but it's on the plate
and i think the pitcher can kind of
psych himself in a position where he
thinks all he's got a good breaking ball
hitter
fastball over the middle bounced it over
the mound out in charges
[Applause]
right back to gallon
[Applause]
here comes the 2-2 he swings and misses
straight three
[Applause]
little roller this is nico horner
gathers it in throws the first peralta
is out
swing
[Applause]
[Applause]
so he puts down the sack and a guy in
scores position and two outs
for ortega
there's a liner down the left field area
but pearl is there for the out
outside corner got him
and van meter retired for davies his
fourth strikeout went away
the pitch is swung on and missed strike
three a breaking ball and they got
calhoun
and third bobble down there by duffy and
gallon beat him to the bag they're
loaded bases loaded for david peralta
davies
that's a line driving a base hit out of
the center field brian's not going to
stop
throw into second rizzo with a solidly
struck single
digs one out escobar coming home versio
applies the tag they cut down the run
the tag on bryant
and that's the first down in the third
and now they're loaded and now it'll
bring up jason hayward
[Applause]
looks like he's okay but that was scary
yetis
he went out from underneath him so two
down cubs on top of the diamondbacks
four to nothing corner at the plate
corner swings and lines one for a base
hit down the right field line one run is
in duffy is cruising home he scores
horner to second the throw in time it
gets horner but both runs score and the
cubs extend the lead six to nothing
robinson charinos at the plate to lead
things off here in the last half of the
fourth inning torino swings and drives
one to deep left center field kiss this
one goodbye
robinson chirinos giving the cubs a 7-0
lead sometimes you roll the balls and
the bats out and good things happen
that pitch is popped up by van meter to
center and coming in on it safely
comfortably is rafael ortega to retire
van meter for the first out the 1-2 to
eduardo escobar cole calhoun on first
one out
is swung on and missed that is strikeout
number eight
anthony rizzo holds him on a bit
half-heartedly if so there
2-2 was hit hard to short javi baez on a
hop throws to nico
sends it out to left center that gets to
the wall
peralta down seven nothing will stop at
third it's a double for pavement who has
singled walked and doubled today
then at second and third the pitch ahmed
swings and hits one in the air to
shallow left center field at triumvirate
converging and bryant makes the catch
and no one can tag up
dalton gets it through into left center
peralta scores
here comes pavon smith dalton varshall
in there
at second with a hustle double and it's
seven to two
robinson shirinos leads off the last
half of the sixth inning for the cubs
in the year left field deep and he's
gone yard again
[Applause]
third hit second homer what's that you
say mr robinson
marshall hits it deep to center dalton
marshall there it goes
the power starting to show for dalton
varshall calhoun
first on the ground softly hit baez
collects
and that'll do it
cubs win